[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
baby 900 pages of Hana them and I got a
really couple months ago and right
through it and I figured well no this
will take a while
I'll they kept speeding up and because I
got completely drawn into the world I
think you will be and as I started
getting toward the end you know it's
hard to be an ordinary pup left I
started slowing down so ii want to leave
the world a benefit I got to the end and
I realized that pink of every single
sentence in the book we need it at the
end of the story what was I going to be
now well obvious I went back I started
reading the book again and beginning to
see how he did that and several people
I've known I would say in the Rose is
one of them this is a book you read
twice that's like whatever now the
gospel says the literature is that which
the more you see the more you read it
and it's in that category I think this
is partly because besides being writer
Neal Stephenson is also a cougar
he writes code would he even writes
about code in the beginning was the
command line was one of his prey that
stays and he writes the way it could
pose in a sense of you're having that
barrel a bunch of things in mind so all
your lines of code know about each other
and he can do some stuff with modulation
and so on so that they don't all know
about each other all the time and
nevertheless they're on a clock and they
gotta know he writes with that kind of
clarity and density but it's a little
bit not completely source code so it's
not documented
you're reading along and there's stuff
going on and there's words and there's a
world that's like earth but not worth
and you're figuring it out and he's got
a glossary and he's got a timeline of
the history of this particular world and
part of the fun is figuring out the
world as you go that's also one of the
reasons it's really fun to reread one of
the characters says at the beginning the
deal we made was kneelin with
everybody's we're not going to be any
spoilers tonight
anywhere that's it I just read a
seven-digit ebook for sell one of the
characteristics that one of his promises
he's got an attention surplus disorder
and what's interesting about this book
is that one that makes you sort of
lightning does and see a little that
part of it runs with people who do that
you have an attention surplus deserter
and Neil has enough with one that is
present in the writing and third what
he's teaching us the readers is to have
an attention surplus disorder which is
exactly the intention of the long now
foundation so that Neil got some
inspiration from Danny Wilson's 10,000
years lock some years ago anyone
is public locks would be designed and
that designing opened this book when
there's a clock actually simulating
clocks in the middle of the action is
important this is the the book is this
evening is the seminar about long term
things this is what happens when an
author and as we join him most readers
take long-term seriously because this
world was Danny Hillis says it's a great
story that takes place and then
ultimately how people take the long term
seriously and it turns out to be and
it's tremendously rewarding and
attractive and this way to one leave the
book you don't want to leave that world
but well now it's here build a person
outside so all this is actually
happening some stories all the
characters all the beginning characters
in books think it's sort of singing and
within the singing their appearance they
are reciting some of the numbers of pie
and those of you who want to stay
afterwards we're going to do an
experience with the working with these
folks cellular automata champion
we tried it a little while ago in a
green room and it is amazing to do by by
the review sticker after that I believe
we're now a little more
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
this is all about a book it is all about
an author now you find that many of you
have these little cards if you want to
write questions on that they'll come out
the Peter Schwartz and Kevin Kelley he
will process them and pass them on to me
and after Danny Hillis talks for a lot
of me will join in on some of your
questions well there's himself
so I'm just going to read
this is the very opening of the book if
I try to read something from later it's
full of spoilers and and vocabulary that
you don't know yet so seems like
starting from the beginning is the way
to is the way to do this dear neighbors
burn one another alive was how FRA Orolo
began his conversation with artisan
Fleck embarrassment the filming
embarrassment is something I can feel in
my flesh like a handful of Sun warm mud
clapped on my head
do your shamans walk around on stilts
FRA Orolo asked reading from a leaf that
judging by its Brown this was at least
five centuries old then he looked up and
added helpfully you might call them
pastors or witch doctors the
embarrassment had turned runny it was
horrifying my scalp along a spreading
frontier when a child gets sick do you
pray
sacrifice to a painted stick or blame it
on an old lady now it was sheeting warm
down my face clogging my ears and
sanding my eyes I could barely hear
froth or lowes questions
do you fancy you will see your dead dogs
and cats in some sort of afterlife Orolo
had asked me along to serve as
amanuensis it was an impressive word so
I had said yes he had heard that an
artisan from extra morose had been
allowed into the new library to fix a
rotted rafter that we could not reach
with our ladders it had only just been
noticed and we didn't have time to erect
proper scaffolding before a pert Orolo
meant to interview that artisan and he
wanted me to write down what happened
through drizzly eyes I looked at the
leaf in front of me it was as blank as
my brain I was failing but it was more
important to take notes of what the
artist said so far nothing when the
interview had begun he had been dragging
an insufficiently sharp thing over a
flat rock now he was just staring at
aura low
has anyone you know ever been ritually
mutilated because they were seen reading
a book artists inflect closed his mouth
for the first time in quite a while
I could tell that the next time he
opened it he'd have something to say I
scratched at the edge of the leaf just
to prove that my quill had not dried up
fra Orolo had gone quiet and was looking
at the artisan as if he were a newfound
nebula in the eyepiece of a telescope
artisan Fleck asked why don't you just
spiel in spiel in frot or lo repeated to
me a few times as I was writing it down
I spoke in bursts because I was trying
to write and talk at the same time when
I came that is before I was collected we
I mean they had a thing called a spiel
II we didn't say spiel in we said
cruised the spilling out of
consideration for the artisan I chose to
speak in pluck ish and so this
staggering drunk of a sentence only
sounded half as bad as if I'd said it in
orth it was a sort of moving picture or
a low gasp
he looked to the artisan and switched to
flesh we have guessed that to spiel in
means to partake of some moving picture
praxis what you would call technology
that prevails out there moving picture
that's a funny way to say it said the
artisan he stared out a window as if it
were a steely showing a historical
documentary he quivered with a silent
laugh it is praxic orth and so it sounds
quaint to your ears fraud or low
admitted why don't you just call it by
its real name spilling in yeah because
when FRA Erasmus here came into the math
ten years ago it was called cruising the
spiel II and when I came in almost 30
years ago we called it Forest Park the
avout who live on the other side of
yonder wall who celebrate a poor only
once every hundred years would know it
by some other name I would not be able
to talk to them artisan flack had not
taken in a word after Forest Park Forest
Park is completely different he's
you can't watch far spark content on a
spiel II you have to up convert it and
reparse the format fra or lo was as
bored by that as the artisan was by talk
of the hundred errs and so conversation
thudded to a stop long enough for me to
scratch it down my embarrassment had
gone away without my noticing it as with
hiccups art is inflect believing that
the conversation was finally over turned
to look at the scaffolding that his men
had erected beneath the bad rafter to
answer your question fraught or low
began what question the one you posed
just a minute ago if I want to know what
things are like Eckstrom euros why don't
I just spiel in Oh said the artisan a
little confounded by the length of FRA
or Louis attention span
I suffer from attention surplus disorder
FRA Orolo like to say as if it were
funny first of all Frollo said we don't
have a speedy device the lead device
waving his hand as if this would dispel
clouds of linguistic confusion Bora lo
said whatever artifact you use to spiel
in if you have an old far SPARC
resonator I could bring you a down
converter that's been sitting in my junk
pile we don't have a forest park
resonator either said FRA or allo why
don't you just buy one this gave Orolo
pause I can sense a new set of
embarrassing questions stacking up in
his mind do you believe that we have
money that the reason we are protected
by the secular power is because we are
sitting on a treasure hoard that our
millinery UNS know how to convert base
metals to gold but FRA Orolo mastered
the urge living as we do under the
Cartesian discipline our only media are
chalk ink and stone he said but there is
another reason - yeah what is it
demanded artisan Fleck very provoked by
fraud or lowes freakish habit of
announcing what he was about to say
instead of just coming out and saying it
well it's hard to explain but for me
just aiming aspilia input device or a
forest bark chambre or whatever you call
it a spiel e captor that something
doesn't collect what is meaningful to me
I need someone to gather it in with all
their senses mix it round in their head
and make it over into words words the
art isn't echoed and then aimed sharp
looks all around the library tomorrow
Quinn's coming instead of me he
announced and then added a little bit
defensively I have to counter strafe the
new clan axe recompensate errs the
fan-out trees starting to look a bit
clumpy if you ask me I have no idea what
that means or a little marble never mind
you ask him all your questions he's got
the gift of gab and for the third time
in as many minutes the artisan looked at
the screen of his GG
we did insist that he shut down all of
its communications functions but it
still served as a pocketwatch he didn't
seem to realize that in plain sight out
the window was a clock 500 feet high I
put a full-stop at the end of the
sentence and aimed my face at a
bookshelf because I was afraid that I
might look amused there was something in
the way he'd said Quinn's coming instead
of me that made it seem he just decided
it on the spot FRA Oh low or low had
probably caught it too if I made the
mistake of looking at him I would laugh
and he wouldn't the clock began chiming
provide' that's me I said then I added
for the benefit of the artisan apologies
I must go wind the clock I was wondering
he said he reached into his toolbox and
took out a polybag blew off sawdust
undid its seal which was of a type I had
never seen before and withdrew a silver
tube the size of his finger then he
looked at FRA or lo hopefully I don't
know what that is and I don't understand
what you want said FRA or lo a speedy
captor ah you have heard about
provenance as long as you are here you'd
like to view it and make a moving
picture the art isn't knotted that would
be acceptable provided you stand where
you are told don't turn it on fra Rolo
raised his hands and got ready to avert
his gaze the warden regulan will hear of
it she'll make me do penance I'll send
you to the eita they'll show you where
to go and more in this vein for the
discipline was made up of many rules and
we had already made a muddle of them in
artists with flex mind by allowing him
to venture into the destined Aryan math
I had been using my sphere as a stool I
traced counterclockwise circles on it
with my fingertips and it shrank until I
could Palm it my bolt had shifted while
I'd been sitting I pulled it up and
yanked the pleats straight as I careered
around tables
Cera's globes and slow-moving froth I
passed under a stone arch into the
scriptorium the place smelled richly of
ink maybe it was because an ancient FRA
and his two fits were copying out books
there but I wondered how long it would
take to stop smelling that way if no one
ever used it at all a lot of ink had
been spent there and the wet smell of it
must be deep into everything at the
other end a smaller doorway led to the
old library which was one of the
original buildings that stood right on
the cloister it's stone floor 2300 years
older than that of the new library was
so smooth under the soles of my feet
that I could scarcely feel it I could
have found my way with my eyes closed by
letting my feet read the memory worn
into it by those gone before the
cloister was a roofed gallery around the
perimeter of a rectangular garden on the
inner side nothing separated it from our
weather except the row of columns that
held up its roof on the outer side it
was bounded by a wall openings in which
gave way to buildings such as the old
library the refectory and various chalk
halls every object I passed the carven
of book gave Venice the stones locked
together to make the floor the frames of
the windows the forged hinges of the
doors and the handmade nails that
fastened them to the wood the capitals
of the columns that surrounded the
cloister the paths embed of the garden
itself every one had been made in a
particular form by a clever person a
long time ago some of them such as the
doors of the old library had consumed
the whole lifetimes of those who had
wrought them others looked as though
they'd been tossed off in an idle
afternoon but with such up sight that
they had been cherished for hundreds or
thousands of years some were founded on
pure simple geometry others reveled in
complication and it was a sort of riddle
whether there was any rule governing
there
still others were depictions of actual
people who had lived and thought
interesting things at one time or
another or barring that of general types
the diaw litter the physiology the
burger and the slime if someone had
asked i might have been able to explain
a quarter of them one day i'd be able to
explain them all so that's the opening
it's being narrated by a roughly 18 year
old about which means somebody who has
literally sworn a vow to live in in this
place called a math which is built
around the giant clock and has a wallet
pierced by a gate that opens once every
10 years so by definition the people who
live there are people who've decided
that they only want to have contact with
the outside world every 10 years or so
and in the Society of this world they
are they tend to be the illiterate
people the scientists the mathematicians
and so on I've been working on this
project for three or four years now and
in the early going as a way of getting
into the moon I would go to concerts of
Medieval and Renaissance music whenever
I could in the Seattle area and that
meant frequently attending concerts by a
couple of groups called capella rolana
that's a Portland based group that does
byzantine chant and the Tudor choir
which is a Seattle based group that does
Renaissance the livening kind of similar
to the Tallis tolerance if you know who
who they are so a couple of years ago I
was going out to dinner with David Stutz
a friend of mine X Microsoft person who
has retired and now works as a
professional musician and he and our
wives were going to
of a group called trio medieval which
again as you can guess from the name
does doesn't really acapella choral
music and I over a couple bottles of
wine explained the premise of this book
and we spun up an idea that I assumed
would disappear and never be heard of
again after we sobered up which was that
it would be amusing to try to actually
create the music that the about the
people in these concepts would actually
make and structurally it might have a
lot in common with medieval liturgical
music of the planet Earth but the key
difference is that instead of glorifying
a religious idea this music would have
the purpose of glorifying some idea from
mathematics or science or a philosophy
that the eval felt to be particularly
beautiful and David went to work on that
and has composed a number of pieces
which are being released today on a CD
that is available through the long now
foundation all profits from the sailing
CD and once we recoup the fairly minimal
cost of production and are going to go
to the longhouse found a
and David's here this evening David
chair missed evening with some of the
singers who performed on the CD you've
already heard a couple of pieces all of
them are built around mathematical
themes except for one called
lament for the third stack which is a
historical piece so we're going to use
we're going to we're gonna have
performances by the singers as as
interludes between the other parts of
the program today and we're going to
[Music]
[Music]
computes the prime numbers which is
mysteries now we're going to do one
piece
where's the lyrics when literacy report
which is the language and Jeremy's
bursting here is person who did
[Applause]
[Music]
and Thomas Thompson live a Strandberg
will supply
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
we're going to do for a few minutes is
basically Danny Hillis designer at the
10,000 year clock
and he'll see them soon we built a clock
before he did get some questions from
you coming up a little bit from these
guys and those little imps here you
don't this got started the book got
started in the mid 1990s at a hackers
conference in Reno so tip of the hat
glint any and anybody else is involved
with the hackers conference to see if
darkness and that was when I first heard
about Danny's idea for the 10,000 year
clock and we and Stewart was at least
one of these two and and so I remember
talking to both of you guys about the
idea at the time I think that between
the two conferences that I'm remembering
I went on a trip to Eastern Europe and
went to a lot of no towns where they had
nice old town square town halls where
the clocks were stopped and in my mind
the stop clock in the Town Square became
a kind of emblem of a society that had
something wrong with it and it wasn't
working so I think when I came back to
the second one of these I asked was
thought that you were thinking of was it
going to be an incredible engineering
tour-de-force that would run for 10,000
years with no human intervention or was
there going to be some kind of human
institution connected with it that would
keep it running it was for me
[Music]
about four years and where people yeah
that was
I think 1999 and long now foundation was
getting ready to do an upgrade on the
website and asked me and several other
people to contribute sort of back at
napkin sketches not necessarily a
serious engineering proposals but just
convey a sense of how different people
were thinking about the idea and so what
I do was something that this was toward
the end of the millennium obviously and
so there was this thing going on where
at the end of every year of course the
newspapers all published the end of year
whose roundup which always makes me
wonder why I waste time at the morning
reading the newspaper and filling my
head with a bunch of stuff I forget 24
hours later when I could just save all
that time I just read the roundup at the
end of the year but they were also
publishing the end of decade roundup and
some of them were publishing end of
century and end of millennium round
offices so the sketch that I drew had a
big clock in the middle and then a
system of walls around it and gates in
the walls that were connected to the
workings of the clock like the doors of
a cuckoo clock and the theory was that
the doors would open at certain times
certain intervals of time and while they
were open anybody was free to go in or
out you know school tour groups or
whatever but if you were on the inside
of the gate when the door closed you
were making the commitment
to remain there until the next time that
it opened and during that time not to
have contact with the outside world so
that's the thing I think you're
referring to that went up on the on the
website swings picture in this 2001
space la vez a bit of this kind of a
time and that was in the sixties and
then I said mystic weather will be given
to the eighties people were still just
thinking about you know 2000 wasn't like
the future it stretched out so it was as
if the future had been shrinking many
times but such a good story I'm gonna
repeat again which was the story about
the old beams of New College Oxford
which was common room was built
centuries ago both being beginning to
deteriorate from this century they
needed to replace them
but then you can just go down to a
bunker guarded by a 40-foot beam so they
started asking around they realized that
Oxford before us Forster and so they
have any big up trees and he said we
have the ones that were planted to
replace the Biebs result the future show
the millennium was causing us to really
miserable futures so the clock was
originally a project about thinking
about that long-term future and trying
to do something concrete and as an
engineer of course I think what it's
amazing to me about Neal's focus its
really played through that idea very sir
Sir what if you lived in the world where
people really didn't think about the
future in that kind of way that kind of
long-term thinking I should probably
mention just to be clear did this may be
obvious to most people here but I'll say
that when I started this thing I just
went off on my own and
and rotate and at a certain point I
started asking myself whether it might
cause confusion in in some people's
minds as to whether I was trying to
predict the future of the world in
general and and of Danny the long now
foundation project in particular and I'm
not trying to do either one of those
things and so that's one of the reasons
that I made the decision pretty early on
to have this book situated on a
completely different planet because I
want to make it clear that everything
here although it's definitely inspired
originally by the by the clock idea and
by the theme of long-term thinking in
general isn't it isn't really about the
the long now foundation or the clock
that they're building and if you know if
you know what these guys have been doing
and you compare it to the descriptions
of the clock and the book and and the
way that the society runs I think it'll
be that'll that'll all be clear to you
but I did want to say it explicitly in
the way I'm since and it's not a
prediction or a future because I really
like the world that you build yeah it's
actually a world in which sort of geeky
guys like me get some left alone on it
we have our own
the world lets us do whatever we want as
long as we don't actually build anything
we just think about it and then I think
it sounds to send a nice world for
everybody else because they're sort of
left too long like the technologists to
there is that I mean we see the these
people living at a time of relative
tranquility in a place that's 3,400
years old and the system's basically
working pretty well for most of them but
the world is also morally ambiguous in a
lot of ways and it's it's not really
ever made clear for example whether the
whether the the first about decided to
to go live in these monastery like
settings or if they were forcibly
rounded up and herded into them like a
system of sort of intellectual
concentration camps so that is left
pretty ambiguous throughout most of the
book and it's made clear that there have
been outbreaks of violence when the
people on the outside just got
completely freaked out by sort of not
really knowing what was happening inside
those walls and came in and tore them
down and big terrible events called
sacks so that the piece that we just
heard performed was actually a lament
for with the the third sack number three
of three at the time of the books right
so it's it it does have very attractive
features if you're a geeky person who
just wants to be left alone and think
about stuff but it's it's
anyways well one of the things that
interests needed that Neal's doing with
the separate set of super nerds is
they're basically the secular society
which treats them as a tourist
attraction
they're tolerated they're not too much
trouble because you don't have to pay
for anything they serve take care of
themselves they aren't even saying every
knot then you go and visit and there's
this kind of strange interface
interaction but what's in a great long
want a Black Swan a bad big threatens
this world at that time to what people
who are capable of solving big bad and
frequent problems and then they're not
just a tourist attraction anymore
there's a the system that's described in
this book of all the basically all the
literate rational people living behind
the walls is called the reconstitution
and it took place thirty-seven hundred
years earlier during a historical period
very similar to what we're living in now
on earth and it's it's a pretty formal
and in structured legal document in a
way we don't get to see the document but
but it's clear that there's various
rules and clauses and procedures built
into it and and one of the reasons that
that the avowed are sort of tolerating
and allowed to live the way they do is
because every so often the secular power
the people on the outside have a problem
that they need to have solved and more
often than not it's something like a
cure for a disease or building some new
technological gadget and so there's a
mechanism in place by which the secular
power can kind of
and pluck out one or two of these people
and take them out of that world forever
and put them to work in a lab somewhere
doing something of a practical nature
and we see that mechanism in operation
early in the book there's also as
Stewart alludes to an extraordinary
mechanism for doing this on a mass scale
and pulling out thousands of these
people all at once and bringing them all
together in something like site foo I
guess to to solve a huge problem so you
want guess one of the things that I love
about it is in fact you get you do get
very technical in many places with the
Richter clock and with the sort of
science and the philosophy of the
mathematics that's another thing that's
really interesting is the relationship
between mathematics and music actually
curious if that was the same time Brian
Eno was working on the gulp permutation
he see things like now what did that
come out of sort of physics thinking or
the Brian's more you know what was the
what was that connection between the
altmer limbs and music David can speak
to this better than I can but the the
way that project went was that we would
look around for interesting bits of math
interesting proofs or theorems things
that were so cool are beautiful we would
talk to two mathematicians and and and
fix on something that seemed like it it
it might be the kind of thing that would
get the about excited the kind of thing
that they would want to to glorify in a
piece of music and then David would
would do some kind of profoundly
mysterious creative process where he
figured out a way to map the the
formalism or the structure of that
mathematical idea on to a piece of music
and part of the one of the premises that
he was working from was that the in the
in the course of the thousands of years
in the history of this world that the
different the different maths the
different monastic communities will come
up with different musical traditions in
the same way that if you in the world of
medieval chant you can listen to a
Gregorian chant or a byzantine chant and
they're both kind of doing the same
thing but they sound very different from
each other they have different
conventions they're expressed in
different language so yeah the Aria is
coming to an end anyway
so so each one of the pieces is
different later on there's going to be a
participatory project that people are
welcome to are encouraged to stay for
where we'll turn up a group of people
into a cellular automaton but but
they're all different and they're meant
to be a sampling of different styles of
mathematical music taken from different
eras of this of this world there's
almost a yes/no question is there any
direct influence of term on ss Magister
Ludi
game in this book no people keep asking
me that but I simply haven't read the
book it sounds like a great book I
haven't read it
I love when it's that clear
here's your question and then boozes
with linguistic creativity why what do
these very very realistic languages do
for your fictional world and for your
readers and there's an inspiration
question that is tolki have anything to
do with this well the language the
questions have been a bit complex there
are a number of English like words that
I had to derive and just in order to
tell the story and the book was written
and basically finished with that
vocabulary which ended up in in its in a
glossary in the back of the book and all
of those words are are kind of me
stretching English words and Latin and
Greek words and kind of recombining them
to make words that sound good to me and
fill certain roles when the music
project reached a certain point we
needed we needed lyrics so some of the
some of the music doesn't really have
lyrics it's just vocalizing sounds but
we wanted to have lyrics for things like
the lament from the third stack and I'm
not yeah it's good to know your
limitations so I'm not a Tolkien I am
NOT the kind of person who can come up
with a dead classical language on the
fly so so I started looking around for
someone who might might have those
skills and in Jeremy Borenstein
volunteered you've seen him on stage
tonight doing some of the singing so
there is now the beginnings of a fourth
language that's that jeremy has put up
on a web page and when you hear some of
the words spoken and the music that's
what you're hearing it did also feed
back into the text of the book at some
point in mostly in improper names like I
went through and stripped out some of
the old proper names that just sounded
like bad Greek and replaced them with
with worth names that I thought were a
little less lame
this is one of those you've been writing
for a while questions and you know Snow
Crash that he had kind of engage on
through genomic on the Baroque cycle and
now anathan this one quickly to another
for you or is this each one just a new a
new the crypt nomicon was a break from
the previous books but it led to the
free baroque cycle books and then so
those were all kind of a set and then
after that I decided I should do
something different because I've been
working with the same set of themes and
the same families for about eight years
or something and I didn't want that I
felt like if if I kept doing and I'd
spend the rest of my life with that so
added them is a complete break from from
those so I'm curious I've already
admitted that I would really like to
live in this world do you do you find it
attractive or would you actually like to
be there as opposed to the worlds and
other forces yeah this one's not too bad
I mean it's interesting people people
throw around the word dystopia quite a
bit and I'm never entirely sure what
they mean had yeah I think people who
are using our extremely restrictive or
well extremely broad definition we're a
dystopia is any world that's not perfect
so if you see anything negative at all
in the world if it's sort of even
realistic somebody will will seize on
that and call it a dystopian and that's
already happening with this I don't
think it's that dystopian I think it
kind of reflects you know kind of on
average about as bad or as good as as
this world is but it's certainly got a
cool place for foreigners deliver rickly
large black letters is the question
what's that thing behind you
so as we're building the clock we're
building prototypes various pieces of
the cloth and this particular thing
behind us is called the chime generator
and it is something that will be
actually in the clock
but this is a labor of love for a lot of
people over over many years and the
basic idea is that when the clock chimes
every trying and trying it plays a
different sequence and this was Brian II
you know that is that this is the kind
of thing only marina we've noticed that
the number of days in 10,000 years is
almost exactly equal to the number of
permutations of to the balance so he
observed that and then we designed a
mechanism that would actually play
through every permutation of balance
over good at 10,000 years so every day
when you wind the clock it plays a
different sequence so it is an
algorithmic it's a it's a random number
generator in effect but it will generate
a sequence that every day is a different
permutation of ballots we're going to be
demonstrating it okay so what's going on
is as busy and you can see that there's
basically
vacation going on the distributing the
sequence that will eventually read the
chimes at the clock right now it's just
hitting these little these little balls
don't think that the amplification is
picking it up right now probably not
hearing the actual ringing but
[Music]
[Applause]
actually took long enough to surf the
sound that we're probably well into
their 7000 when they're not exact
alright you've been living in the
innocent world even more than your
readers so the question is do you find
yourself needing or using the vocabulary
in your book in your life now in general
can you talk about how anathan hiss
infused the way you want mister the
world and speaking for myself it's
infused the way I wander through the
world and then the earlier is noticing
about the secular world all the kind of
shallow and tedious and eesti I don't
know this this is one of those questions
that calls for great deal of self
reflection and self awareness and self
consciousness which are habits that I
really try to avoid because I find it
I find them to be so counterproductive
when it comes to literary output so so I
would have to ponder that one for for a
good long while I will say that I've
been increasingly troubled the last few
years by how little time I spend reading
books you know I know that it's because
it's it's because I'm spending time
instead doing email surfing the web and
that kind of thing and I I would very
much like to get back into a habit of
spending more time and time alone quiet
and devoting a lot of spans of time to
reading stuff and in a strange way the
answer to that or an answer is going on
a book tour since spending vast spans of
time and Airport departure labs just
waiting for the air traffic controllers
to give me permission to take off and so
on
prisons are kind of interesting the
technical question it's argued that the
medieval monastic system theocracy is an
actualization of Plato's Republic do you
see this is a perhaps a better
realization of the version of Plato's
Republic
well not Plato's Republic the book is
it's all about mathematical Platonism
and these people have a philosophical
tradition that dates back several
thousand years to their equivalent of
Athens and their equivalent of Plato and
Socrates and they they use formal
philosophical dialogues as a means of
pedagogy and of hashing out ideas with
each other and they drop into these
dialogues at the drop of a hat
so there's a lot of that in the book
maybe maybe too much for some people's
comfort but anyway they spend a lot of
time talking philosophy and end of the
the idea that they're mostly talking
about is is mathematical Platonism which
is the idea that you know i guess a
succinctly to put it is that that three
was a prime number of billion years ago
even before there were any human beings
who could think about prime numbers or
or say what it meant to be a prime
number the three was still a prime
number if you believe that you are some
form of plainest and it's a it's it's a
it's a pretty common way of thinking
among mathematicians and scientists
today it's I think in humanities
departments is it's taken about as
seriously
the idea that lightning is caused by a
angry God on the mountain throwing
Thunderbolts made by his crippled
half-brother or whoever biases lesser
but but it's a really serious kind of
philosophical issue and and people have
people are thinking about it in a
serious way today if you look at the
acknowledgments webpage you'll see links
to to some people who thought in a
serious way about this within recent
centuries and decades just to give you
an idea of how much mathematicians or
heroes in this book that's that's one
point in the book it's a very complex
situation where the the fate of the
entire world is threatened and the
sitting around one of the mathematicians
is very optimistic well we have a
protractor
I guess so move on to the next stages
here that they've got a question for
each of you Danny I want you to want to
think about whether you sort of by the
the Profi and the Platonic idea in the
book that there is if you are dealing
with engineers from another world you
would have a lot to talk about and to
talk with is one of the conceits of the
book I think and I just wonder not that
this book helps you reflect on that and
related that Neola I'd like to know
whether you take the philosophy and the
book and especially as you have your
characters take it and as you teach your
readers to take it and the philosophy
looks kind of decorated for a while and
then it turns out it's actually quite
essential so where do you come to on the
philosophy should start beginning
well I got hit square I mean in some
sense that conceded the book that you
say that you could communicate to people
that we can make a connection to people
in the future that we really don't know
much specifically of that and so they
might have a completely different
culture than ours so they completely
different language are completely
different at the world but in some sense
we're assuming that the basic idea of a
clock that keeps time and the algorithms
that are there to make the planets there
are few set of Givens that make a
connection between us premise of the
book and in some sense that's the
Platonic ideal answer to the second half
of the question I do take it seriously
that the once in a blue moon if you ask
mathematicians about this once in a blue
moon you'll meet one who's not a plane
ask but for the most part they tend to
believe that when they prove a theorem
they are they're not making it up
but they're uncovering something that's
really out there and there really exists
and there's all kinds of of sound
reasons to feel that that's the case so
even though out and out Platonism has
been kind of a dead letter in in some
areas of
philosophy for a long time people like
Kirk Godel took it extremely seriously
and devoted a good part of the last half
of his career to working on it and to
countering the objections of positivists
who he felt were attacking that idea and
who were peddling a really unsound way
of thinking about this
so go ahead I just want to see something
about what the idea was that we're
talking on that which is that you know
there's some amazing thing in
mathematics that you do these
manipulations of arbitrary symbols on a
piece of paper and you do something like
calculate what electron is going to do
and then somehow the real world actually
does those stuckness so there seems
almost a magical connection between
these equations that are writing is this
arbitrary formalism it's almost like
music or something like that it's
something that really happens in the
world so this is sort of fundamental
mystery why should the world be like
that why should it be that we came off
of the room and somebody can solve some
equations and you know predict that if
you do this experiment
[Music]
lakeville ballistic container the
molecule will do a certain thing why
should the world well it kind of forces
you to believe in really spooky stuff
like the notion that there's a platonic
world out there were all of these pure
forms and ideas kind of live and they're
eternal and they're unchanging and
somehow it can exert a causal effect on
things in this universe because we're
living in this universe when the
mathematician sits alone and with the
pencil and paper and does math according
to this idea that mathematician is
perceiving things that belong in this
other realm so the realm is making a
cosmic effect relationship on this
universe but we can't exert any
reciprocal cause-and-effect relationship
on it so that just seems really spooky
and weird and unsound when you put it
that way and and so hence can't all of
the discussion one more basically yes or
no question in the most of your story
reads science fiction or do they read
only full science fiction well they talk
about it it's called specfic in the
world of the book and they're aware of
it but if they they they can't see
anything that's more reason than the
last time that there
gates opened so they they might look at
it as kind of old historical documents
but I guess the basic answer the
question that is that this is not one of
those very weird science fiction
universes in which there is no science
fiction recursion there to close with
we're gonna have one more here the music
and then various things will continue
and you're welcome to stay look what
happened is dorsal opening to both parks
will open into the bookstore people
you've already ordered will want to get
a free signed book that's on the left
hand back door and people who are
getting a fresh book and want to get it
signed as long as since me nuts rolls
out line going out this door
also there will be two things going on
in here of the appearing I want to stick
around for one more conversation
what is the chanting using this
wonderful device that allows
us to become cellular automata singing
according to a cellular sequence of
events that will surprise all of us the
other thing is there is a form of
martial art in the book that is referred
to at one point is Shawn foo there's a
there's a little more that's more
there's a little martial art element
that goes on and I understand we can
have a demonstration of that probably on
the stage said enough the audience gets
hurt and that's where we are
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]